I did General Hospital and let me tell you something,
if I would've gotten off a plane and on General Hospital,
I would've gotten fired.
Thank God.
I was P at 12 and 13 years and I knew my way around the set it.
You know when you book a soapbox but nobody talks to you.
You do know that.
Yeah.
Like you walk into seep ABC over there and oh God street.
You walk in,
they will get your id and then go go to room 27 you go to your office,
you fucking your suits.
That when I saw the lady comes in and she goes,
how you doing?
My name is Mildred.
Watch the TV and look for your numbers to come up.
So you sit down and you write your numbers.
I'm in the scene 27 chapter eight and you sit there with wardrobe on,
but you would,
I would go there at eight o'clock and I'd be in my car and a quarter at a time.
Really?
How many soap operas?
General Hospital.
Three episodes.
I find that
three episodes and general hospital's amazing.
I played a recovering fucking preacher who had been in prison and I came out and
now I was a fucking marriage thing,
bro.
When they called me,
they called me and they're like,
we're interested in you sending a real.
And I'm like,
wait,
whoa,
whoa.
So Benjamin Bratt,
those good looking dudes.
They started on general hospital and you want me,
I generalize.
Fuck.
Are you fucking crazy?
I sent them a real,
I swear to God.
My agent's like,
they really want your real Joey.
What do you want me to do,
man?
Go send it to.
What do you want me to do?
It never going to hire me,
bro.
They called right back.
Come on down for three days.
Wow.
You walk in there,
Joe Rogan,
you give me your Id.
It's that fast.
You go to your room,
Oh,
say seen 28 prepare wardrobe.
You're 10 minutes away.
You put whatever wardrobe they give your on.
They have cue cards for you.
Uh,
they have a year under a fucking under the cameras.
It's a three camera shoot.
You go out that says,
okay,
acting number 28 come out.
You come out,
I ain't doing job welcome.
Very nice to meet you.
Okay,
let's do this.
Action.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Let's say you fuck up your line.
They don't give a fuck like I'm you start from all are now starting from that
line.
Bop,
bop,
cut.
Moving ahead in Austin,
they switch you out,
blah blah blah.
They put makeup on you and they're like,
you're not in the scene.
Just sit over here for five minutes bro.
Five minutes they come right back to you.
All right,
you're ready.
You're in the same three and you're like,
what the fuck does that pop?
Pop,
pop,
pop by Bob,
your wrap.
Thank you for coming down.
Nobody talks to you and nobody does nothing.
So it's not a,
they're just trying to get it out quick.
They don't hold Jan.
It's eight to five.
Wow.
Being on a soap opera,
it's probably the easiest.
Like have you landed on General Hospital?
You can be on general hospital,
but there he is.
That dude's but on ever 30 years,
you know you could be on there.
People been on it for a long time.
It's eight to five in your hospital.
Is that Luke and Laura?
I was.
That was Luke and Laura.
Right.
Remember Luke and Laura do that?
It was one.
I got it to happen.
There was a thing that happened in and soap operas and it happened while I was a
kid.
Luke and Laura transcended general hospital and became a thing all throughout
the world.
These people,
well,
yeah,
these people didn't make sense because the dude's hair was weird and it was a
strange cup.
All the scene with dog.
They were weird.
Yeah,
I did the scene with him.
She was a little too hot for him.
It didn't make a whole lot of sense,
but it worked for whatever reason,
it caught fire culturally and became a big thing and I think I was in high
school at the time.
Their wedding,
it was in 1983 okay.
Yeah,
so I was in high school while I was in high school.
This was all going down and everybody paid attention to Luke and Laura.
It was like the general hospital thing took over the country.
It was like in the cover of people magazine and Shit.
It was everywhere.
It was just one weird relationship on a soap opera for some reason.
Just became this gigantic phenomenon that everybody was watching.
I mean,
I was watching it.
I would like I said,
30 million viewers.
Crazy.
What was,
what was the show with the good look of singer?
I wish that she was Jessie's girl.
Oh,
Rick Springfield.
General Hospital.
Same Shit.
And I watched that,
but it wasn't even him.
See if him,
if he was with Laura,
I watched that before.
He's a handsome son of a bitch that Rick Springfield,
you know,
and he was a double threat.
He was on general hospital and he was a bad ass singer.
That Jessie's girl,
that song,
if you're at fucking like wild wings and Jessie's girl comes on,
you're getting silent getting of it.
Jesse is,
he's still out there hitting it.
Still touring.
You still tour?
I think he was at the Canyon Club in a Gora
is out there.
That dude was a,
when I was in high school,
that dude was on top of the fucking food chain.
Every girl at a poster hill on the wall.
He's in Lake Tahoe next month,
February.
Good for him.
It's crazy that whatever soap opera was on from 12 to one was a big time soap
opera and there was a bar in New York and there was a bar in New Jersey and my
neighborhood that if you walked in there from 12 to one and you said a word,
somebody would tell you to shut the fuck up and it was 98% men and they would
serve lunch and it was the one I would go to was the midtown lounge,
but there was another one.
So there was a lunchtime soap opera that men left Ed jobs,
full construction guys and they would sit down and watch this soap opera on two
TVs like it was a Yankee game.
What the fuck?
And then they will go back to work.
No strange is that,
how strange is that?
That was a thing.
It was like one point and I still remember,
you know if you dated a girl and she stayed in on Wednesdays to watch dynasty
bitch,
you stayed in on dynasty night.
If that's what it meant to go to get them.
Nikki cookie.
Dot.
Makes sense for like today it's translatable.
You know,
Sunday night game of Thrones is on or whenever night it's on.
It's like people do get together and they watch it live as it goes on.
That makes sense.
What doesn't make sense?
Is that the market for those kinds of soap operas was it,
it was appealing to men and high school kids.
Like we were all watching it.
Who shot jr Bro.
That's Dallas.
But that's a no,
no,
I understand.
Now we're talking to then not only were they sucking you in the daytime in those
days,
this was all the eighties were talking about the eighties correct.
Okay.
What the fuck was going on at night?
All right.
You had Dallas and you had,
what was the one on ABC?
Uh,
with Alexis Carrington Dynasty and the guy is Steve.
That was bad as a bad ass shit.
That girl right now,
the check who played the princess on that,
that was supposed to be Alexis's daughter and she was having an affair with
Dexter Dexter.
She's the one right now.
That's going through that thing with her daughter and the sex ring up in
Connecticut.
There was like a sex ring,
Novo or whatever.
Like a,
she's a princess.
Real life unconscious.
Yes.
She's the one that's going through all that with the daughter.
I remember her being on dynasty has a hot hot,
and she was Alexis,
his daughter,
but Dexter Dexter was Alexis Alexis's husband.
She had some Dex,
Dex,
Dexter.
I've been a real name is that,
look at that cast.
Joan Collins.
She's still hot back then.
She's the original mouth,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.